Well I was hoping to come to you today, and tell you I have such great news
We got close enough to the 500 new financial supporters to make some really exciting things happen
We've hired someone. They're here, and it was all gonna. Be just so exciting and amazing
And up up and away, but sadly I I have terrible news for people today
I have actually disastrous news genuinely. I always I and Pat also try to find silver linings in
Literally everything that has ever happened on or related to the program, but I don't think there is any silver lining here
We've been hacked and we've lost
quite a few thousands of dollars in
previous show revenue from an account with coinbase now coinbase is the largest
Cryptocurrency exchange and we use coin base to receive
Cryptocurrency that is contributed by viewers and listeners
We also use cryptocurrency to be paid for some of the ad deals that we make with companies that
account has been hacked and
We've lost many thousands of dollars now. There's an investigation going on I want to focus
really on a solution here
I don't you know what what happened happened coin base has totally locked up our account which also by the way
means we can't get any of our other money out of it for the time being until the
Investigation is complete which could take more than a month
and I
Basically, you know we don't I don't want to give every single detail as to how this happened
but we were having an issue with our coin base account and I both submitted a ticket through the coin based website and
Contacted the official verified coin based Twitter account and that coin based Twitter account
asked publicly for our ticket number and
You know my better instincts did not kick in and I should have realized that publicly sending a ticket number
Would be a very very bad idea
And could be misused, but hey, this is coin base
This is the top
Cryptocurrency exchange in the world if their security protocol says it's okay for them to publicly ask for ticket numbers
Then I sent it. I had a lot going on yesterday and that information combined with
Effectively a Daxing of sorts that took place was able to be used by a hacker scammer
To take a bunch of money from the show that that's the bottom line we're in touch with
The FBI because this is a theft of money right the idea that it's cryptocurrency doesn't mean
Many thousands of dollars were stolen and that is of course a crime and my optimistic there will be a resolution, no
What I am asking you to help with is to politely
Contact coinbase either through both of their Twitter accounts coin base and coin based support
Or by emailing press@coinbase.com which I believe is
more actively monitored and
say
The david pakman show really got crushed and it all goes back to that request for a public ticket number
That really shouldn't be your protocol
But we need you to help the David Pakman show coin base in the past has been known to compensate
Individuals who are in these situations?
They've also been known not to compensate individuals
Who are in these situations so I wish I had some positive spin to put on this, but it's really really bad
Yeah, it's been a tough year for the show I remember last year
We were getting more views than ever more ad revenue than ever because of the election and write Trump's inauguration
Then we got hit by the YouTube advertiser boycott yes, and things went downhill from there recently
We've been getting into cryptocurrency and doing these ICO reviews
and we got hit by the same thing and we got hit and also in between those two things in the last 12 months we
Got completely shut down from our Amazon affiliate link as well, so yeah
It's the the the show audience has never been bigger and yet we continue coming across these stumbling blocks
And you know one of the worst parts about this Pat is
Even though a bunch of our crypto was stolen not all of it was but we no longer have access to the stuff that
Wasn't so even though
several thousand dollars were stolen
Effectively we have access to none of it now because even the stuff we have is all tied up
For security reasons while coinbase conducts this investigation which again can take a month or more yeah, I found a silver lining though, okay?
That's we still have our members and our patrons
Yes
And we still have our health
and I think that that's an important thing not to lose sight of people always say that you know at least you still have your
Health and you've not been physically victimized and and all of that is true
So again less I mean number one number one. We need to see how much money we can get back
I do believe that there is some liability here by coinbase publicly asking for ticket numbers rather than saying
Direct message us a ticket number
Or do not send any ticket not write this thing send us your ticket number publicly is a real problem
So I do think that there is some liability there
We need to see how much money if any we'll get back number two
Have to get that account cleared and reactivated so that we can actually resume operations since that account is really important to what we're doing
I'm mobilizing every resource that I can but I am coming to you for help in pushing this along so press@coinbase.com
Tweet to @coinbase and @CoinbaseSupport explain that this is a huge thing that
You are watching what coin base is doing because I think the the possibility
That they don't handle this well, and that is publicly discussed will maybe get them moving on this
and I promise you that if they do handle this well and and
appropriately
I will update you as well right so it's not just that I'm out here
Complaining trying to trash a company coin base is a company that has done right by us
Exclusively completely up until this time
more than a month of our money being being tied up with no
Positive resolution would be a disaster so help us you can say this is all related to
@dpakman or @davidpakmanshow on twitter or david@davidpakman.com
I wish I had more to say I don't but it's it's not been a good 24 hours
That's for sure. The video you just finished watching was made possible by you through the membership program
You can sign up for membership at david pakman.com slash membership. We are viewer supported independent media
You can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of your membership